fromage de chèvre orange produits
préparés ou congelés la dizaine de
bénévoles des restos du coeur de
courville sur eure distribuer les
denrées aux bénéficiaires des personnes
au rsa souvent des femmes seules avec
enfants la responsable de l'antenne
finit d'ailleurs les inscriptions et
elle constate une très légère
augmentation des demandes
c'est un peu près un petit peu en
augmentation pour nous c'est pas énorme
par contre les gros centres lui c'est ma
vie des sharks de demandes en plus des
demandes en plus pour moins de bénévoles
au siège départemental il manque en
effet des chauffeurs manutentionnaires
et comptable côté distribution
la relève est plus facile à trouver
comme olivier bénévole depuis cinq mois
qui veut donner de son temps
j'ai passé une période où j'étais un
petit peu critiqués on m'a aidé donc
maintenant je le donne aussi donner de
son temps et une écoute attentive
c'est aussi ce que recherchent les
bénéficiaires comme gérard qui vient ici
depuis cinq ans content là de revenir
avec l'ouverture
et puis il ya deux ans on discute et
tout ça parce que moi je suis tout seul
ça le change
gérard fait partie des quelques 5600
personnes accueillies par les restos du
coeur d'eure-et-loir
il reviendra à courville tous les mardis
jusqu'à la fin de la campagne
à la mi mars et pour aller plus loin sur
le sujet on écoute patrick petit aux
bénévoles en charge du stock aux restos
du coeur de courville quelle catégorie
de personnes viennent aux restos du
coeur
si vous voulez on a deux catégories de
gens de gens qui ont du mal à retrouver
du travail des gens qui sont simplement
de passage qu'on va garder pendant
quelques mois pour leur donner un petit
coup d'un petit coup de main
le temps qu'il retrouve une situation
mais c'est vrai qu'on a de plus en plus
de femmes seules avec des enfants
chômeurs
et quelques retraités manquez-vous de
bénévoles en eure et loir
oui tout à fait les professions dont on
a un besoin urgent des caristes des
chauffeurs en comptabilité en
informatique aussi pour gérer les stocks
en informatique
pourquoi est il difficile de recruter
des bénévoles pour la manutention et
l'administration cariste déjà se
dépenser ça demande un certain diplo
chauffeur pareil
comptabilité c'est quand même une
profession bien spécifiques
peut-être aussi que c'est pas très
attractif parce que nous on a un contact
donc avec le bénéficiaire donc quelque
part c'est valorisant tandis que se
retrouve dans un bureau à gérer comme
des produits ou des dossiers c'est vrai
que c'est pas très passionnant non plus
mais par contre c'est très utile
il faillit la gare elle nous a rejoints
en plateau bonsoir faïza c'est donc le
cas aujourd'hui que les restos du coeur
lancent leur campagne hivernale partout
en france
absolument alors on vient de voir cette
antenne de courville sur eure 2 sachez
qu'il y a une antenne départementale
partout dans la région
on va voir la carte il y a un siège à un
gréalou c'est à blois à saint-doulchard
à tours et à châteauroux
toutes les antennes qui dépendent de ces
sièges ont commencé à distribuer de ne
pas dès ce mardi
maintenant on va regarder les chiffres
le nombre de bénéficiaires il a été
assez stable sur les années qui viennent
de s'écouler on compte 130 millions de
repas
l'hiver dernier avec huit cent soixante
mille bénéficiaires
un chiffre assez stable sur les années
qui viennent de s'écouler mais si on
regarde sur dix ans en arrière
il y avait 100 millions de repas
distribués et 800000 personnes qui en
ont bénéficié ce qui vous donne qui peu
l'idée de l'évolution ces chiffres ont
en réalité exposé sur ces dix dernières
années
regardons de plus près les chiffres dans
la région sur cette carte qui va suivre
vous allez voir en orange là où il ya
plus de 5000 bénéficiaires envers moins
de 5000 dans la région c'est drôle loire
à elle qu'on distribue le plus de repas
et qu'il ya le plus de bénéficiaires
exactement 8612 hiver dernier
c'est dans le cher qu on en distribue le
moins et qu'il y a le moins des
bénéficiaires avec 3400 personnes qui
ont été accueillies par les antennes de
ce département alors le profil des
personnes qui ont bénéficié de ce repas
a lui aussi évolué on compte beaucoup de
jeunes il y en a de plus en plus les
moins de 25 ans ce sont le public
majoritaire de l'association et puis il
ya de plus en plus de retraités aussi
est-ce que les dons augmentent aussi
alors que oui en fait il faut voir les
les sources de ces dons les dons privés
sont les plus importants 94 millions
d'euros les subventions 62 millions
d'euros dans ces fonds un gars les fonds
européens qui sont très importants et
puis il ya les recettes des emplois des
les recettes des disques et
puis les tournées 15 millions d'euros
avec ces chiffres vous comprenez que
l'association compte énormément sur la
générosité des français en fait elle
craint que cette générosité fc bis un
peu il y ait des alertes en ce sens les
appels aux dons qui ont été faits au
démarrage de l'hiver ou démarrage de
l'automne ont été moins fructueux que
l'an passé et puis d'une manière
générale on donne de moins en mois
malheureusement les associations ont
toutes constaté qu'il y avait moins de
dons en ce début d'année 2010 8
malheureusement merci beaucoup faïza
pour cet éclairage